[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
NIAMH GAFFNEY: I'm
a bit freaked out
because there's so
many people here.
And I have a bit of a
confession to make--
I kind of got you all here
under false pretenses,
because as much as
I would love to,
I can't teach you how
to control change.
No one can.
No, you can go if you want to.
That's OK.
But no one can.
And before Caroline
starts freaking out
about her P45 or
anything, I promise,
there are things that we can do.
But change impacts us
from the very second
that we're conceived.
And most of the time,
we wouldn't notice it
then, but most of the time,
we don't even notice it.
We are a child, until
one day we're an adult.
We're young, until one day we're
not fit for Coppers anymore.
And you, being in a place
like this, until one day
we're the person
showing people around.
We're a high-flying executive
flying all around the world,
until one day we're
claiming the pension.
We're sick until one
day we're healthy,
as anyone who's had the flu
recently knows all about.
And equally, we're
perfectly healthy, living
our normal lives,
until one day we get
a diagnosis that change it all.
And like I said,
most the time, we're
happy enough because we've
created this idea that
normality is no change.
We don't notice the single
gray hair appearing.
We don't notice those
small little bits and bobs.
And then something powerful,
something unexpected,
something unwanted happens,
and it changes all that.
And we realize that normality
isn't all of these changes.
Normality is change.
Normality is all of that.
I just want to show you--
I talk too much, but actually,
it might be easier just
to show you guys.
If you close your eyes for a
second and find your pulse--
for anybody who doesn't
know where the pulse is,
it's in your neck or in
your wrist or in your heart.
But find it.
And I can assure you,
it's definitely there.
As you feel it, close your
eyes and see in your mind's eye
the graph that it's making, the
ups and downs, ups and downs.
And if you're on this
side of the audience,
guaranteed it's going an awful
a lot faster than normal.
But then just take your
hand away for a split second
and continue to see that graph
and just see it fading out.
See it, those ups and
downs, smoothing out.
It's all normal.
It's all calm.
It's all controlled.
But there's not much
life going on there.
And that, ladies and gentlemen,
is what I can help you with.
Because normality isn't
a place that we all
run to when we try to get back
to normal after a big change
happens.
Normality includes
all of that change.
Normality is where we have
to take those changes.
We have to do
something with them.
We cannot avoid them.
There is no such thing
as going back to normal.
You take it all with you.
And I've just realized, because
I'm thinking about my own heart
rate, that I've forgotten
the lovely images that
go with that.
But what I want to show you
is that-- and does anybody
recognize this quote?
And anyone who does
is kind of going,
I'm not admitting
that I recognize that.
It's-- yeah, I know.
I'm giving up all
my secrets here.
But it's from Harry Potter, that
well-known point of reference.
But it's so true.
No matter what happens,
there is always something
that you can do-- always,
no matter what it is.
And it's all about taking
that bit of control,
reaching out, and
turning on the light,
no matter how awful your
experiences and your changes
may make you feel.
So I know it's not normal
to open your laptops
and things like that here.
But what I'd like us
to do, rather than just
you guys sit back
and listen to me,
I'd like us to use
this as an opportunity
to create solutions
for whatever changes
that are going on
in your own life.
The first part of that is
naming it, naming that darkness.
So if you'd like to open your
laptops or a piece of paper,
if you have it, or your phone,
and write down something
that you're dealing
with right now.
You can write down a code name.
If you haven't any paper
with you, if you can just
think about that and
bear that in mind as we
go through the exercises.
Because what happens when we
are faced with this change
is we lose sight of the
fact that life is change
and we lose sight of
the fact that this
is what it's all about.
And when that happens, we get
that feeling of out of control
and we crave for that
sense of normality.
And to give you an idea of why
I talk about things like that,
I suppose I'd better
introduce myself a little bit.
Five years ago, I was worried.
I had just had a little baby.
I was on maternity
leave and I was worried
about going back to work.
How would I be
perceived at work?
What had happened with
the team while I was away?
Maybe I'd be overlooked
now for promotion prospects
because I couldn't commit in the
same way as I had done earlier.
I was worried about the commute
up and down and the crush,
and leaving at 5 o'clock,
thinking, god, maybe people
think I'm on a half day
when I leave at 5 o'clock.
And then I got a diagnosis
of aggressive breast cancer,
and I wasn't so worried
about the commutes
then at that stage.
So what you can do
in those situations,
you freak out, as you do.
You cry, as you do.
But then there's no
way out but through it.
You get on with the treatment.
You do what you're told.
You kind of give up those
choices and that control,
and that's part of it.
And you have to do that, because
there is only one way out,
and that's through it.
Well, I'm here today not in
spite of all those changes
and things that happened to
me, but I'm here because of it.
I couldn't have stood in front
of you guys five years ago.
I just couldn't have done it.
I probably wouldn't have
anything to talk about.
But that's beside the point.
I suppose I just want
to impress upon you guys
that we run away a lot.
We avoid a lot when we're
faced with scary changes,
with traumatic changes.
Because those changes can
range from being mild anxiety,
if you're worrying about
asking someone out on a date
or asking for a raise, to
intense trauma, when you're
dealing with bereavement or
a life-changing diagnosis
or anything scary.
However you experience
it is totally normal.
That's the way you're
supposed to experience it.
But trying to run away from it,
trying to find this normality,
that doesn't work.
And especially, I don't know--
I'm sure you guys have come
across it, where something
has happened and it's all over.
And then people say, ah, great,
you can go back to normal now.
The thing is, I couldn't go back
to my pre-cancer me, anymore
than I could go back to
my pre-motherhood me.
I just couldn't.
It's not possible.
So when you see things like
human evolvement even--
is that the right word?
Charles Darwin had
it right when he said
the survival of the fittest.
We're not all walking
around on all fours anymore.
We let go what we
needed to let go of.
We took with us what we
needed to take with us.
And we changed to make
it so that we can now
walk on two feet.
Our whole skeleton has changed.
And that's the point
of today's talk,
because we can always
do three things.
The first, we choose.
We choose what's
important to us.
The second, we change.
We change our perspective.
We change our position.
And the third is we control
the actions we take.
If you use all of those
three steps, no matter what
whirlwind picks you
up and pushes you
in a completely different
place, no matter
how change impacts you,
you can get on with it.
And not only can
you get on with it,
you can become who you need
to be and you can evolve.
So the first step is
getting clear, then,
on where we want to go
after these whirlwinds.
And it's ironic
that I'm here today,
because anyone who knows me
knows that, quite literally,
the best thing that
ever happened in my life
was Google Maps.
I know.
It's ridiculous, but it has
literally gotten me here today.
Because not only--
no, it's unreal.
No matter how often, no matter--
I've forgotten what I was
going to say there now,
because I'm kind of thinking,
where did I park my car?
Really, I am bad at that.
But, oh, yes, of course.
The best thing
about it, the thing
I love about it is that not only
does it tell you where you need
to go and how you
want to get there,
it tells you where you are and
the direction you're facing in.
It's incredible.
And when I went through my
own thing that we all have,
when I went through my own
whirlwind, I was totally lost.
I wasn't the person I
had been before that.
It frightened the
life out of me.
And then I realized that
every single one of us
has our own internal GPS system.
And we can call that
fulfillment or meaning or values
or whatever you want to call it.
But what it boils
down to is this--
it's what is important to you.
That's it.
If you know what's
important to you,
and you know that,
and really know it,
then every decision you
take, every step you take
is done with that in mind, and
it makes life so much easier.
Because wherever that
whirlwind drops you,
you can find out where you
want to go, where you are,
and the direction you're facing.
It still doesn't help you
with where you parked the car.
But that's by the by.
So what I'd like you to do is
close your eyes for a second.
We'll do a little exercise,
if everyone's OK with that.
And at the end of it, hopefully
you'll get a real sense of--
a little sense of--
what's important to you.
So close your eyes, please.
And if I can ask you to take
a deep breath in and out.
Deep breath in, and
breathe out fully.
breathe all the way out.
Now, you will notice
the sounds in the room.
But as you hear my voice, you
become more and more relaxed.
You can feel the weight of the
chair supporting you, if you're
lucky enough to have a chair.
And for those of you who
are standing, hold on.
But you become more
and more relaxed.
You are calm, safe, and relaxed.
In and out.
Now, I want you to imagine that
you have just been given one
week to live, just seven days.
You feel the shock of hearing
that, the horror of having
to tell everybody you love.
This is your last Friday.
But you also begin to notice
that you have the freedom
to do exactly what you want.
These are your seven days.
These are your last seven days.
You can choose what
you want to do.
What is important that you do?
What is important that you say?
What message do
you want to leave?
What do you want to
do with the people
you are going to choose
to spend the time with?
What is important that those
people remember about you?
What would you be brave enough
to do that you're not already
doing?
Or perhaps, what would you stop
doing that you're currently
spending too much time at?
Now I want you to think
about that challenge
that you wrote down.
If you had seven days to live,
what would you do about it?
What's important about that?
In a moment, I'm going to
ask you to open your eyes
and just record down
one thing that you
can do about your
challenge now that you
know what's important to you.
Take a deep breath in and out.
And when you're
ready, open your eyes.
If you can make a
note of those things,
any thoughts that you have
about what's important to you.
Maybe something you
didn't realize you're
spending too much time at.
So what we've done there
is change your perspective
a little bit.
And actually, that's
the second part.
Because we don't see
things as they are.
We see things as we are.
And we are all safe and secure
in our lovely little comfort
zone.
And for as long as we
stay in that comfort zone,
we can only see things the
way we've always seen them.
So when you try to
challenge those boundaries
and push out the edges of that
comfort zone a little bit,
you start to
understand that there
are other solutions, other
ways of thinking about things.
And that can help you get
solutions to the problems
that you're facing, no
matter what that is.
So it's very definitely
easier to blame whatever it is
and be a victim
of the situation.
But actually, our
responsibility is to ourselves.
To keep that line going up
and down on our heart rate,
we have to step up.
You have to move out of the
place of being a victim.
And one of the
ways we can do that
is to change our
perspective and get
a different insight, a different
way of thinking about things.
So what I'd like you
to do is, everyone,
if you could just
bring to mind your most
positive relationship,
somebody that you look up to,
somebody whose advice you
take on and you actually hear,
rather than just listen to.
And have a think
about it and imagine
what they would do if they
were faced with your challenge.
What would they do
if they were faced
with what you're
looking at, what you're
worrying about right now?
What would they suggest you do?
If something comes to mind,
make a quick note of that.
Now, I'd like everyone
to stand up, please.
And I'd like you to pick
somebody else in the room
and swap places with them.
Have a look at them as you're--
have a look at them.
It's what they--
[INDISTINCT CHATTER]
Now, as you take their
place and as you sit down--
as you sit down in
their place, I'd
like you to look at that person
and imagine that you're now
wiggling your toes
in their shoes,
if you can stand
to imagine that.
They might be a different
gender, a different culture.
They might see things
a different way.
They might be a different
managerial level than you.
But guaranteed, one
thing's for certain,
is that they can see things
differently than you.
How would they deal
with your challenge?
What would they do if they were
faced with the thing you're
worried about?
Have a think about
that for a second
and see if you can come
up with one solution
that you wouldn't have
thought about when you're
standing in your own shoes.
Do you get a fresh insight
from that perspective?
You can always go and stand
on the top of Everest.
You can always--
well, maybe you can't.
But all the astronauts
who've left this world
have come back with
a fresh perspective
and have changed their
whole lives as a result,
because they've seen things
from a different place.
That's what you
guys are doing here.
So look at the person whose
space you've just taken
and find out and challenge
yourself to think of one thing
that they would suggest that
they would do in your position.
OK, go back to your seats.
Go back to your places.
[INDISTINCT CHATTER]
And as you sit down this time--
as you sit down
this time, I'd like
you to age yourself 25 years.
What would your older self
say about your challenge?
If you are 25 years
older, you've already
lived through your challenge.
You've already asked that
person out on a date.
You've already
asked for a raise.
You've already dealt with
the cancer or the headaches.
Or you've already done
your driving test.
You've already managed to
live through that change,
and you've evolved and
changed as a result.
What advice would your older
self give about the thing,
about the challenge
that you're facing,
the change that
worries you right now?
If there's anything that
you can gain from that,
please write it down.
Or take a moment later
to go through it when you
have time to think about it.
So like I said, this
exercise creates
lots of just positive
relationships with yourself
and it shows you that there is
life outside your comfort zone.
And it's a gentle way of
doing it, rather than having
to actually sit in
the consultant's chair
and listen to that news.
Being pushed out of your
comfort zone like that
allows you to take
responsibility
for the situation and allows
you actually to gain control
over the situation.
Because you then are able to
not only know what's important,
but you're seeing
different ways.
And you're coming up
with your own solutions
to things, solutions
that aren't possible
when you're dealing with
the fight or flight response
that change can often cause us.
My third step for
dealing with change
is the whole notion of control.
Because there is always, always
something that you can do.
The problem is, we're not in
the habit of thinking like that.
Our brains are incredible.
They are an incredible
tool of efficiency.
But if you've always
thought the way you think,
you'll always get what
you've always gotten.
And changing your perspective
and choosing what's important
are ways of challenging that.
But no matter how much
you do that, unless you're
willing to step up, put
on your big girl pants
and get on with it and take
action, nothing will change.
And you will continue to
be a victim of that change,
rather than the driver of it.
So what I would like you to do
is to think of three things--
write them down, if you can--
that you can do right now that
will further your challenge,
that will help you move
through that challenge.
And those things can be as
simple as having a cup of tea
so that you can get the mental
space to think about it.
We don't actually think about
things in a positive light
very often.
We worry about things.
We ruminate about things.
But we don't actually think
it through in the same way
that you would
deal with a project
or spec out a new design.
You only get one chance at this.
It doesn't matter
whether you have
seven days to live or 70 years.
But if you're not behind
the driving wheel,
it doesn't matter.
You might as well be having
one of those flat lines.
So there's two principles
to bear in mind
with the whole area of control.
The first, like I said, is that
you can always do something.
And I'll teach you
the three small things
that you can always, always do.
They're kind of an emotional
first aid box, if you will.
And the second thing
is that action actually
creates confidence.
When we're faced with
an unexpected change
or an unwanted change, the
first thing that happens
is we're impacted.
We feel we can do nothing.
You feel that you're
out of control,
that everything is
happening to you.
And you have no confidence in
your ability to do anything.
And a lot of the time,
you don't have any ability
to do anything.
I certainly couldn't come
up or dish out the chemo
that I had to get.
So in that respect, yes, you
do give up a lot of control,
a lot of choices in
those situations.
But the thing is you haven't
given up all control.
You haven't given
up all choices.
And the more action
you can take--
in the same way as a journey
starts with one step, the more
action you can take, the more
momentum you can build up,
the easier the next step
becomes, the next step,
the next step.
So if you're worrying about
asking someone on a date
or asking about a raise,
schedule a meeting
or send a text.
Do one small, tiny thing
that gets the momentum going.
So if you can think--
I'm going to just
give you a moment
right now to think and
write down three things
that you can do as
soon as you leave here
that will further your change.
Things that not only you can
do, but things that you're
committing to doing.
If you can take a moment to
write those down, please.
This exercise is
very, very good for--
and the physical act
of writing, actually.
Writing even more so than typing
or jotting notes in your phone.
The physical act
of writing has been
proven to be an action in itself
and can allow you the space
to get to the end of a thought.
And if you can get to
the end of a thought,
you're eliminating the space
that the worry can creep in.
So the more and more
you write, the better
it is for your ability to
come up with those solutions.
So I promised you
a few other things
to add to your "I can"
list, and the first
requires a little
bit of visualization,
if you don't mind once more.
Don't worry, you're not going to
get a death sentence this time.
But if you can sit with your
bum to the back of your chairs
or sit as comfortably as
you can be on the floor,
I'd like you to put your
feet solidly on the ground
and wiggle your toes
so that you can feel
them connect to the ground.
And feel your hands
heavy in your lap.
And close your
eyes for a moment.
I want you to breathe in deeply
to the count of 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
And out slowly, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
And breathe in again.
And breathe out fully.
Now, I'd like you to think about
your very worst day at work,
the worst day that ever
happened to you at work.
Remind yourself what
you were wearing,
who was there with you.
Remind yourself what
you could smell.
What was going on?
What could you hear?
What words were being said?
Stay with that memory
just for a moment,
and put yourself
back in that position
of your worst day at work.
And as you remember
that, I'd like you just
to notice the thoughts
that are coming up.
Maybe they're the thoughts
that happened on that day.
Perhaps you were feeling
you're not good enough.
Perhaps you've been told
Perhaps you're feeling you're
going to get caught out or that
your work isn't as
good as other people's.
Perhaps you're noticing feelings
of anger, of disappointment,
shame perhaps, or maybe
guilt or regret or fear.
Are people blaming you?
As you notice those
thoughts and memories,
I want you just to
notice the reaction,
your physical
reaction right now.
Is your heart rate getting
a little bit faster
as you remember those feelings?
Perhaps you're
reminding yourself
of the knot in your stomach
or the crick in your neck.
Perhaps your breathing is
a little bit shallower.
This is your physiological
response to the fear,
to the anxiety.
This is your flight
or flight response.
But with your eyes
still closed, I'd
like you to take your
thumb and your index finger
and rub them together
ever so slowly, ever so
lightly, so that you
can feel the ridges
of your fingerprints.
Perhaps you've
never even noticed
that you can feel them before.
But you can feel every
ridge and every furrow
on your fingerprints.
Now, using your thumb and your
middle finger, do the same.
How are they different?
Is there a difference?
What you notice right
now is that as you
do that, it's impossible
to think the thoughts
you were thinking earlier.
As you concentrate on
finding those lines,
you realize you're not able
to do the two things at once.
SPEAKER: We'll be through
with this problem any minute.
NIAMH GAFFNEY: This could
easily be my worst day at work.
But we'll get past that.
OK, everyone's got
their eyes open again.
[LAUGHTER]
But what I just want you
to notice, hopefully,
before you got interrupted
by whatever that was,
is that doing something
like that, that fingertip
mindfulness, if you like--
mindfulness is an
incredible thing.
It's great.
I hate it.
I'll be completely honest.
It's like, oh.
I love the notion of it.
I love the idea that I can be so
calm and in control of my life.
And the reality is, it's
like, yeah, I'll do it once,
and then it'll be another week.
And ah, sure, I'll
do a bit of that?
It doesn't work for me.
And also, no matter how
good, no matter how great you
are at practicing mindfulness,
when you're freaking out
because your boss
has just called you
in to talk about a report,
when you're worrying
about something, when you're
sitting in a consultant's chair
and you're worried
about the information,
you can't pop off and
do a bit of mindfulness.
You just can't.
So this is incredible.
You can do it quietly,
you can do it quickly,
and it gives you the tiniest,
tiniest little bit of space.
That's all you need to put
in place one of your I-cans.
Because if you can do
that, then your brain--
what happens is
that your brain is
starting to open up
those pathways that
have been closed off to you.
When the fight or flight
response is triggered,
what happens is you literally,
literally cannot think.
You can't think because all
of your mind's resources
are focused on the danger.
And those parts
of your brain that
deal with the memories and the
creative solutions and things
like that, they're
literally blocked
by all the cortisol and the
adrenalin in your system.
Doing this kind of
bypasses the fight
or flight response
for a split second,
and that's all you need.
It gives you the space to think.
So that is something that
you definitely can always do.
The next exercise-- and I'm
going to ask you to stand up.
And I'm going to ask you
to go with me on this one.
And believe you me, it's
better if everybody's eyes are
closed on this one,
because nobody comes out
of this looking glam.
What I'd like you to do
is just drop down anything
that you have your hands.
And for the count
of 10, I want you
to squeeze every single muscle
you can as hard as you can,
including your eyes, your
bums, your tums, your legs,
your toes, everything
for 10 seconds.
Go, 1, 2--
I'm not seeing any eyes close.
Everyone do it.
3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10.
And relax, shake it out.
That was ridiculous.
Do it again, as hard as you can.
3, 2, 1, go.
2, 3, 4, 5.
You can definitely
do better than that.
9, 10, and let it go.
And we do it again.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7,
8, 9 10, and relax.
You can definitely do better.
Do it again.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10.
OK, one last time, go.
OK.
Do you feel the difference
in your muscles?
If you've been giving it
all in that, you will feel--
[SIGH]
And that allows you to turn
off your fight or flight--
blah, blah, blah-- the fight
or flight response, no matter
how ridiculous it seems.
You can all sit
down for a second.
This is an incredible
tool for insomnia.
If you're dealing
with insomnia which
is driven as a
result of anxiety,
and you get that fizziness
that goes on in your muscles,
this is brilliant for that.
If you do it about
12 times, guaranteed
you're too knackered to
do anything but sleep.
But you have to go all out.
But equally, if you're--
OK, I'll admit to
being somebody who
can get myself quite wound up.
And once you're in that thought,
you can't think of your way
out.
That fizziness
can be dealt with.
Anybody who loves your
boxing or physical exercise,
go and do that.
That's what it's for.
It allows you to
get more relaxed
and take advantage of that.
But it's not always
possible to go and do
a spot of boxing or
dancing or running.
But you can always take yourself
somewhere private perhaps,
and do that.
And that allows you to get
rid of the adrenaline that
builds up in your muscles.
And by doing that, it gives
your body and the amygdala
the signal that the danger has
passed, rather than getting
stuck in a vicious cycle
of stress upon more stress
upon more stress,
which is what happens.
The final thing that we can
do, and we can always do,
is-- like I said, action
creates confidence.
So how about we get a
little confidence hack,
something that will
give you the confidence
and fake it until
you can make it.
Now, I'm sure some of you
have heard this before,
but I'd like you
to stand up for me
and give me your
inner superhero.
If put your feet hip distance
apart and arms on your hips--
you can close your
eyes, if you want to.
But I'd like you just to
think how incredible you
look in Lycra, how
brilliant it is to have
your own special superpower.
What would your superpower
be, if you had one?
If you had that
superpower, how would you
deal with your challenge?
If you can keep your head
up and your tummy tucked in
and really, really
feel that superpower,
feel how powerful
you actually are.
Probably better to do without
putting your underpants
on the outside of your
tights, but go with whatever
you need to on that.
So this has been
proven to increase
your testosterone levels.
But it's also been proven to
decrease your cortisol levels,
which is the very
hormone that's blocking
those pathways to the
memory banks and experience
banks of your brain during
the fight or flight response.
So when you do feel
anxious about something,
it's very easy for us to say,
oh god, I couldn't do that,
or I won't do that,
or try and avoid it.
If you can do something as
simple as this for two minutes,
you're allowing
yourself to boost
your feelings of confidence.
But you're also
allowing yourself
to take that one action, to
take that one step to create
that momentum.
You can all sit.
And thank you for
going for it for me.
These things are only
small tools, guys.
Like I said at the start, I
can't help you control change.
My god, I wish I could,
because I wouldn't wish some
of the experiences on anybody.
Nobody wants to go
through the horrible stuff
that we go through in life.
But we don't have a choice.
Those horrible things are
as equal a part of our lives
as the gorgeous things
and the lovely things.
You don't get to have
one without the other.
So when we look at a
problem or a challenge,
we can often look
at what we can't do.
And that's kind of where--
we have a habit of that.
And what I'd like us to do,
even just in a small way,
is to stop moving in the
direction of reacting
to change, but actually
step forward into being
the driver of change.
I'm here today, like I said,
not in spite of change,
but because of it.
I've created a new normal.
I've created a life
where I help people
deal with emotional and
mental difficulties.
I'm here today not as a cancer
survivor, but as a mommy,
as a person, as somebody
who's just living.
I think this is a great
quote because, to be honest,
that's the only way that
we can control change.
It's not about
striving to avoid it.
It's not about trying to stay--
going back to normal.
It's about embracing
it, building the new,
choosing what you want,
adapting however you need to,
and going for it.
So every single day,
we're impacted by change.
None of us are going
to change that.
But like I said, we
can change the victim,
or we can change the driver.
We can drown, or we
can surf the waves.
But it's our choice.
Sin , thank you very much.
And good luck with
the rest of your day.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER: I just have a
few questions for you,
and then we've a
few minutes then
to move to audience
Q and A. Just
remember to wait until we
get a microphone to you
for the audience Q and A--
we've one on either side--
so that they can hear
you on the recording.
So my first question is, these
different skills and techniques
that we can practice
that we've heard today,
we can practice them when
we're facing a challenge.
How often do we have to relearn
how we deal with change?
Does it become that, every
time we face a change, we are--
we're back at the
beginning again
in terms of our
reactionary responses?
Or with time, do these
techniques eventually
become almost the
automatic way that we
turn to when facing challenge?
NIAMH GAFFNEY: So the
answer is yes and no.
So the reality is,
is that we're great--
a brain, like I said,
it's a master illusionist.
And it allows us to
believe that those ups
and downs of everyday life
aren't even happening.
So we kind of form
into the habit
of doing things like
that and kind of thinking
of things in the same way.
Tools like these are incredible.
But it's actually--
the importance of them
is only when the
unexpected happens.
And the unexpected,
by its very nature,
doesn't happen often enough for
us to create habits about it.
We can improve, and we
can definitely get better.
And you can get in the habit
of this notion of being
able to always do something.
But actually, when
it comes down to it,
when something unexpected
or unwanted happens,
your reactions are
going to be the same.
You can have your
anxiety and your trauma,
depending on what you're facing.
And that is part of life.
You can't not have that.
So yes, they can help.
But they can only help in the
aftermath of it happening.
They can't help it not happen,
if that makes any sense.
SPEAKER: Yes.
Yes.
Great.
Another question I
wanted to ask you about
is, in lots of
work environments,
and definitely in ours,
we face a lot of change.
Do you notice that people
are more open or accepting
or respond more
positively to change
in one area over the
other, like their work
life over their personal life?
Or in general, do we deal
with them mostly the same?
NIAMH GAFFNEY: I think we deal
with them mostly the same.
It depends on the
importance of them.
So if you are being told
you're being made redundant,
for example, there
are people who
that doesn't matter to because
they've always been considering
of how to move out of that.
It's not an issue.
But there are people for
whom, let's say, the role
is a complete lifeblood.
And so much other things,
what's important to them,
depends on that.
Then obviously they would have
a much greater reaction to that.
My only caveat to
that, if you like,
is that sometimes
in an organization,
we feel we can't react
other than how people react.
And that's why
there's a lot of--
and it's probably
not here as much
as it is in other organizations.
But there's a sense that you
can't be anything other than OK
with change at work.
The reality is-- and that kind
of puts pressure on ourselves
to deal with things
in a specific way.
The reality is,
it doesn't happen.
You're going to feel how
you're going to feel.
And that depends on the
importance of the situation.
But we kind of buy into the fact
that you have to be OK at work.
Even no matter how
many times people
say it's OK to not be
OK, the reality is,
is that there's an expectation.
So I suppose for people
here, be conscious
whether you're
reacting normally,
whether you're acting--
let me rephrase that.
Be honest with yourselves, guys.
That's it.
Be honest.
You don't have to tell anyone.
You don't have to share it.
But at least you be
honest with yourself,
because that's the only way that
you can take your next action.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
It'll catch up with
you eventually.
NIAMH GAFFNEY: Exactly.
Sorry, a big, long-winded
response to your--
SPEAKER: No, a great response.
And that brings me on
to my next question.
And after this question, then
I'll go to audience questions,
so you can have
something in mind.
Is there such a thing as
reacting dangerously to change,
like having a dangerous
reaction to a change?
And what are maybe some
of the warning signs
that the person's
response isn't going
to be good in the long run?
NIAMH GAFFNEY: Well,
I can't answer that,
to be honest,
because everybody has
their own reactions to things.
And none of us know how
we're going to react
to something until it happens.
Equally, I suppose
what we have to be
conscious of is our
conscious steps.
So when I spoke
about taking control,
taking responsibility
of the situation,
if we have consciously
decided to react in a big way,
and that decision is made with
what's important to us in mind,
then it doesn't matter to anyone
else what that reaction is.
But if it's a reaction
where we're running away
from something, where
we're trying to avoid it,
where we're not
facing up to it, then,
yes, that is a
dangerous situation.
SPEAKER: That's great.
Great answer.
Do we have any odd questions?
NIAMH GAFFNEY: I do a lot
of work with small teams.
So as I kind of
mentioned myself,
that one of the big
worries, for example,
when people go off maternity
leave or long-term leave,
even as well as with sick,
is that so much happens
while you're off.
So much happens for the person.
They've changed
while they're off.
But the team has changed.
So there's often a lot of
alignment to be done there.
And we can do that through
both training and then
individual support, as needs be.
SPEAKER: So are there
any daily actions
that we can take that
would support us or help us
when we do face some
kind of big change?
Or is there anything to be
said for doing little things,
like taking a new route to
work or not always having
the exact same
breakfast every day?
Or will that help you at all?
NIAMH GAFFNEY: Well, for sure
it does, because that is exactly
like I was talking about.
That is the change perspective.
If you go on your bike
ride and you go out
into the forest
without a GPS, or if I
dare to drive without my
own GPS, you get lost.
And you get through that.
And it makes you
think how you would
react in those dangerous
or difficult situations.
So yes, it is all about change.
That allow you to
change perspective.
The only thing we
can do is-- look,
everybody knows what
works best for them.
I know mindfulness and
yoga doesn't work for me.
I don't enjoy them.
But there's so much to be said
for the gratitude journals,
for the mindfulness, for
whatever works for you.
Do that.
But I suppose a bottom
line to all of it
is to figure out
what's important to you
and take action towards that.
Because once you know
that you can do that,
no matter what
life throws at you,
you can always adapt to that.
SPEAKER: OK, great.
And you said during your
talk that we don't see things
as they are, we
see them as we are.
Which is-- it's a great line,
and it was eye-opening for me.
But while I was
sitting there thinking,
it made me realize that this
would encourage us to look back
on our previous
reactions to change maybe
with a kinder point of view.
Because we can be
quite-- like, do you
find that people can be
very hard on themselves
on how they dealt with change?
NIAMH GAFFNEY: For sure.
We have an innate reaction
to, or an innate ability
to look on the dark
side, like never
look on the positive side.
It's all, like, personal
bias and things,
but we never look at what we
did in the best possible light.
And when you can treat
yourself with the kindness
that you would,
without thinking, show
somebody else in your life, it
changes the whole perspective
of things.
I don't know, has anybody
ever been in an experience
where you felt that something
had happened one way,
and then when you spoke
with somebody else about it,
they saw it in completely
different light?
That's the same situation.
You would never,
ever, ever treat
another person or
a person you loved
the way you treat
yourself in your head.
You would never do that.
You wouldn't dream of it.
And yet we do it all the time.
So when I talk about
being conscious of making
those decisions, you
can't stop those thoughts.
There's no point even trying.
But you can challenge them.
And that's one thing you can do.
You can always say, hold on now
a second, that's not even true.
It's not true that I never
get to the right place
at the right time.
It's just not true.
I do, the odd time--
usually with Google maps,
but that's beside the point.
So you have to just be
kind in that respect.
SPEAKER: We've got a
question at the front.
NIAMH GAFFNEY: The thing is,
all you can ever do-- no matter
what's going on,
all you can ever do
is let that person know that
you're there, no matter what.
But you're there being kind,
and you're there being brave.
And you're there
to hold their hand,
metaphorically or literally.
And that's all any of us can do.
There's so many things that
you'd take away and you'd fix.
But actually, fixing it
doesn't resolve anything
for the person.
They're still dealing with
their version of the change.
They're still dealing with the
things that they feel inside.
And no matter what you say or
do, you cannot change that.
And that's what I meant
when I said at the start,
I can't teach you how
to control change.
I can't.
No one can.
So, sorry.
It's a great answer.
I'm telling you nothing.
So--
SPEAKER: And so this a
quick follow-up on that,
because we're getting
to close again.
What are your thoughts
on the phrase--
and even I chatted about
this a little bit further,
and I think you guys would
appreciate hearing it--
the phrase, "Stay positive?"
"Keep your chin up."
NIAMH GAFFNEY: I've heard
that phrase once or twice.
Believe you me, the bald look
does nothing for me, right?
So when somebody says to
you, oh, you look gorgeous.
Be positive.
It's like, are you kidding me?
No, I cannot bear that phrase.
But we say it all the time.
There's two ways
of looking at it.
The first is that it's
completely, completely futile
to be positive when
you're feeling rubbish.
If you're feeling
rubbish, feel rubbish.
If you're being sad or
you're angry, be angry.
God knows it will
come out somehow.
But the other side of
it is that, I suppose,
in terms of being kind and
changing your perspective,
people say things.
They say things because they
don't have anything to say.
And it's a kind of a
way of trying to be
there to support somebody else.
It's like, look, this might
make them feel better.
I'll say this.
I've heard this said.
And it's a kind of a reaction.
Some people feel so awkward
in those situations.
God knows, I was at a
funeral there recently.
And a lot of the people--
when you're sympathizing,
you don't know, let's say,
half the family.
It's like, what do you say?
Oh, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
And then you have that
connection with the person
that you do know.
You have to say something
in those situations.
And that's where the "be
positive" often comes from.
And it's from a good place.
But, my god, if you find it
at the tip of your tongue,
just hold back.
Think of another
way of phrasing it.
Encourage people, I
suppose, sometimes.
I'd encourage people
to be how they feel.
If that's positive, great.
If it's not, please don't
ask them to be positive.
SPEAKER: Great.
I think we have
one final question.
NIAMH GAFFNEY: It's
funny that mindfulness,
for me-- and that's what I
meant by fingertip thing.
It's just to give you
the breathing space.
That's the way I see it.
So for me, I read.
Sometimes when you're
going to bed at night
and you can't shut off, I--
people who do gratitude journals
and mindfulness and all that,
it's brilliant, and
it works really well.
I don't like it.
It makes me anxious,
which defeats the purpose.
But I read.
And then in the reading,
I can kind of switch off.
It's like you can be
out of your own head.
And it's just to stop
that craziness of thought,
that tornado that can go on.
That's one thing that I do.
The other thing is
that sometimes you just
have to get on with it
and just say, OK, I'll
just do one thing, one
thing that you can do.
And even if that one thing
is moving out and going
and getting a cup of tea,
or going outside the house
for a walk, just whatever
that one thing is,
it could be the
tiniest little thing.
But once you feel that
energy, that movement,
certainly for me, that
helps me feel better.
It helps me feel that
I'm doing something.
I don't feel as much of a
victim of the situation.
I'm using "victim" a
lot, but it's probably
the best word to
describe sometimes
how you feel in that situation.
So yes, it helps you
just to do something.
SPEAKER: That's a lovely
question to close it.
Thank you for asking.
Thank you for everything.
NIAMH GAFFNEY: You're
more than welcome.
SPEAKER: And thank you
for coming in to us.
[APPLAUSE]